good afternoon ladies and gentlemen
gentlemen please please take care
welcome welcome
on the okay of the first visit
of
germany me point out that we have
interpretation to and from german french
and english
president you have the floor
yes
thank you very much and good afternoon
to everybody
it i'm certainly
delighted to be able to welcome you mr
schultz as the new chancellor of germany
to the european commission we've known
each other for some years we've been
able to work closely together and
obviously that helps us with the new
roles that we now have
now germany
was always and still is very important
in terms of the historical development
of the european
union german chancellors have always
played a very important role in shaping
the european union
i think that it's a very encouraging
signal that you decided to visit the
european commission so soon in your
chancellorship i think it shows how
important the european union is for the
german the new german government
the coalition agreement has a very
robust chapter on the european union
policies eu policies are throughout the
coalition agreement
i would certainly uh say
myself that the european commission is
open to
very strong and intensive cooperation
with the new german government
we have very important issues on our
agenda
combating the pandemic the fourth wave
of the pandemic
where we're seeing the highest infection
rates in a lot of our member states or
the highest level of infections
generally of course it's the delta
variant that's causing these infections
but there's also omicron omicron the
omicron variant which is present in
almost
every
member state in the european union the
scientific community
doesn't know yet how serious the disease
is caused by the omicron
variant but it's very clear that it's
very invec infectious highly infectious
the um
number of infections doubles every two
to three
days which is of course very fast
the
best protection that we have against
this disease at present is
three doses of the vaccine it's very
good to see that steps are being taken
in germany to improve the vaccine rate
we'll talk about our priorities the
european green
deal
germany is the biggest industrial
country in the european union it can
play a
leadership role
in showing that you can
transform to a sustainable
climate neutral
circular economy
and obviously
we are counting on germany support for
the fit for 55 package
germany is a leader when it comes to the
expansion of renewable energies
the second priority for us is
digitalization
the coalition agreement
expressly supports and the eu chips act
and also the digital markets act we were
very pleased to see that
these legislative packages um
will be discussed under the french
presidency
and it's important
that they shape the
world
they shape digitalization in the world
it's about rules relating to content on
the platforms and fair competition for
smaller
companies compared to these big
platforms and it's very important for us
that these standards be set by europe
and not in other regions by other
regions in the world
obviously foreign policy is the other
area that
is very important for us it's important
that every close
cooperation interaction
with
member states and governments
china
is
a fierce economic competitor it's a
negotiation partner for climate policy
and
in the way it promotes an alternative
model of governance it's a systemic
rival we'll also talk about russia and
their
military activities on the border with
ukraine
we want de-escalation from russia we're
on cessation of all aggression against
its
neighbors it should it should um respect
the sovereign rights of nations
otherwise the european union
would
be looking to intensify its sanctions
and also to
take other measures across
economic sectors financial sectors
obviously every step that we take is
done in agreement with our partners
we want to have a good relationship with
russia just to make that absolutely
clear
but
it depends first and foremost on the way
in which russia behaves
russia
is tending to take a threatening stance
towards its neighbors
which of course undermines europe's
security
so a huge number of
issues that we have to talk about
welcome to you
i'm very grateful that on the second day
of my term of office i've been able to
travel to brussels and that we're going
to be able to discuss the common topics
that are so important for our future
german is a european nation we are a
large country at the heart of the
european union we have a large
population a large economy and that is
why
german politics cannot um
stand um at the side and
simply comment on what's going on no it
has to take on a role of responsibility
for our joint progress and that
will
only
work if um progress applies equally to
citizens and representatives and
i think that the government that has now
been formed all of the partners in this
coalition have a pro-european agenda
but also a large part of our opposition
is pro-european that's the way in which
um
it presents itself in germany
and we
will um do everything we can to push for
that progress now the questions that
have been raised of course first and
foremost um
facing up to the
covid pandemic
and on the basis of all of our
experiences across different member
states it's important that europe uh
stand together and that we um
act in close cooperation and of course
our priorities have to be um
a high rate of vaccination and making
vaccination available and attractive to
everyone and we will keep a constant eye
on the evolving situation the large
upcoming project is industrial
modernization which
should also put us in a place to halt
the man-made climate change
and to grow our economy um
germany hopes to achieve climate
neutrality by 2045 the european union
has set its goal a couple of years after
that but it is of course a huge joint
effort that will be required and i'm
pleased that we are making this effort
and these steps together that has a lot
of consequences for
germany it means that we want to push
the increase of renewable energies so
producing electricity
from wind on and offshore and from solar
energy in such a way
to allow our industry to be climate
neutral
and
that will also be the source for the
additional
electricity that will be needed simply
replacing
the current electricity that is won by
coal
and gas in germany is not going to be
enough we will also need additional
capacity because that is what it will
take to reach a carbon neutral economy
so that's something we're going to have
to work on um
including within the programs put
forward by the european commission such
as fit455 which we are of course
committed to and then
we want to
ensure a strong sovereign european union
and that also means that we have a
closely
coordinated strategy when it comes to
foreign policy the
great
ambition now is to ensure that security
and defense in europe can
be successful and that any
threat towards an individual country is
not tolerated and we are of course
deeply concerned by the events unfolding
along the ukrainian russian border and
it has to be
our
responsibility to ensure that everyone
can feel safe within their borders and
that the borders within europe are
um
inviolable
and firm so these
are
the
basic outlines of our cooperation and
it's nice that we've been able to work
together for such a long time on a
personal level we've
worked together in two different
cabinets and have been able to work
together on various uh files and i think
that that will also help in tackling the
topics that we face a few questions for
our guests from the german media please
press the button and wait until the
right delights are is read
yes please thank you andreas from
reuters
commission president
you were
the chancellor was just in um
in paris
the french president wanted
a change
in the way in which
the european union is
run and you said that the current rules
are very flexible
but who do you feel closer to in the uu
commission ie would you like to see a
change the stability packed or do you
think that it is sufficiently flexible
and then a chancellor a question on the
taxonomy issue
it would be useful
i'd like to
know
what you um think about having nuclear
energy and gas as a transition
as transition technologies that can be
supported
under investment
and taxonomy yes to answer your first
question
we talked
about
um
common ground
we're still within the pandemic
the escape clause is there within the
stability pact we talked about a common
approach within the european union i.e
that we
have
a common
view
of what the situation is
within europe how the pandemic has
affected the economy and the recovery
i.e debt rates deficits also a need for
more investment
so we get the overview and then we will
discuss how we precede afterwards
i'm emphasizing this because i think
it's important that we have a common
view of what the situation is not just
the status quo but also the needs that
we have and how they can then be
addressed with instability pact
and yes just to repeat what i've said
elsewhere
many times taxonomy is not a very clear
word to a lot of people
it should we should of course make it
clear that this is about economic
activities that are then um assessed
according to our climate priorities and
our climate goals it's about
for example promoting the use of solar
energy and wind energy etc
this would then
be a signal to the finance industry
where they should perhaps invest whether
or not that will actually happen we
don't know but obviously
um
we're thinking about how to adjust this
in the best way possible
which is why it's important that uh in
germany we follow our priorities we want
to extend and expand
renewable energy we have clear
objectives
600 terawatts
is consumed we want to increase that to
700 to 800 terawatts by the end of this
decade
and we won and of course we want climate
neutrality by 2045 where we could of
course have electricity needs that are
much higher even twice or three times as
high as now
we need of course a stable network and
that hydrogen should also be used
storage is very important as well
and
production and different industrial
processes obviously
this is all something that will take
time and gas will play a role in the
transition
other countries have a different
priorities
i think that uh we're still discussing
how we're going to achieve this
yes i think that an important point here
is that of course taxonomy
does allow different activities
taxonomy
is about and of course it's about moving
towards climate neutral and neutrality
and ensuring that investment is
targeted to achieve climate neutrality
and it includes those categories which
make a substantive contribution the
first delegated act
has already been adopted it's a
historical step
forward there are also the transition
activities the so-called transition
activities
and this is all part of taxonomy of
course it's not one thing that's going
to resolve all of our problems we need
a
number of measures
all moving towards climate neutrality so
that we we want to target investment and
create investment we want transparency
and clarity for our investors
so that we can steer investment towards
climate neutrality
a question from a correspondent here in
brussels
thank you flor de fellow uh eric
irinizer kadula with the greek public tv
and athens news agency president what
are your expectations from the
cooperation with the new chancellor and
chancellor a couple of years ago most of
greeks put the blame to journey to
germany
for the hard line and the measures that
greeks had to implement
uh because of the financial crisis what
is the message that you are going to
send regarding the fact that the whole
europe faced this coveted situation for
most than two years thank you
so to answer your question we have
positive expectations towards the german
government the new german government
um because we know that all three
parties forming the new german
government are strongly pro-european
and this is important
there will be always issues that we will
have to discuss with all 27 member
states but being pro-european as a
precondition we very much welcome
thank you for your question
um
as you know we worked very hard to
cooperate with greece in the last years
this was also the case when i was the
finance minister and
the people in greece understood that
this was going
really good and now we have a situation
in greece which is really
to be understood as a good process of
growing and
recovering which i appreciate very much
on the other hand you see that we have a
situation
of the situation to fight
the task to fight against covet 19 and
the european recovery fund is a project
which has been developed
by the chancellor and me and was
supported by many other countries in
europe now we are doing this what is
coming from the recovery
fund and all the member states even
greece on knowing
and using their opportunities
and
possibly it might be a good message for
you that not just me but also the
finance minister and in this case the
whole government is very much
appreciating the development in greece
and we want to help all countries that
they will have a good chance to recover
yes
yes
um commission president you uh mentioned
the massing of russian troops along the
ukrainian border and
stated that any escalation may be
subject to additional sanctions and i
was wondering whether putting a stop to
gas line
north stream 2
would be one such possible sanction also
to the chancellor in a recent interview
you said that if there were a violation
of a border by russia that there would
have to be clear consequences
do you think not stream too
as a possible option for sanctions or
would you not go there
isn't it
as the european commission
in june the european council tasked us
with
developing
options on russia and we have done that
to a great extent now and as i
previously said we do so in very close
cooperation with all our partners for us
it's important
uh to stress that any aggression has to
come at a price
and
that is why
we will communicate these points to
russia
but
we'll not be making them public we'll
not be taking
the floor on these publicly but in
general terms it's important to state
that energy can never be
means of exerting pressure and that
energy security of europe and its
neighbors has to be ensured
what's clear is that germany the
european union and many others
would certainly react if there were a
violation of the border but it's equally
clear that
our task at the moment is precisely to
prevent
that we need
to work together in europe and we are in
agreement that borders
need to be
beyond possible violation
yes i have a question for the chancellor
the um coalition agreement
it's
a hundred
pages isn't it and
there are words that
people find visionary or indeed
unrealistic
changes to the treaty of federal europe
or
will
there be treaty changes do you think
during your chancellorship your term of
office or do you think that that's
something that will just be discarded
because some member states just won't
accept it and now a question to you
president commission president
us
the u.s president and russian president
talked about european security with four
nato countries but not with the
geopolitical commission is that
something that you can accept
now you quoted part of the coalition
agreement and you can see therefore that
it's a very pro-european government that
we have in germany
obviously
these are
approaches that we would take together
with our european partners and see
what's possible there are debates about
the future of europe which are currently
taking place
so i was very happy that we took a clear
position
on
this on the reception
that this had in germany it would seem
to be the majority opinion in germany
now you asked a question about the
security architecture of europe i mean
anything to do this the architecture the
security of europe needs to be discussed
with europe of course there's the
current situation
with ukraine we've got the normandy
format which is the right format with
ukraine more general discussions about
security issues that affect
europe
should be the osce i believe because
then all
the
parties are sitting around the table
you